when he's good I'm I want to work with
him I've done lots of shows supporting
him on things like criminal justice
reform staying out of of so many
permanent wars and stuff like that that
he's done but on other things that that
libertarians care a bunch about you know
we just had a vote on on surveillance
power and whether or not the deep state
would get more powered Trump's been
horrible on that
[Music]
where are you generally at with Trump
well I think I think the name Trump was
only mentioned once in this entire
interview just a moment ago I sense with
most libertarians they kinda like a lot
of the stuff Trump has done regulation
cut taxes we don't seem to be going to
extra Wars if anything we're trying to
get out of Afghanistan now and we're not
gonna be nation-building that's all very
libertarian stuff I think a lot of
libertarians and I one night we were at
a I think it was a Yale conference and
we had a table of libertarians and it
seemed very obvious to me that
everyone's sort of like the things he
was doing but just had a personal they
just don't like him personally like it
was that idea and I sense that a lot of
people have that thing is that kind of
where you are what are you making this
whole thing with Trump Trump and the
liberty minded people cuz obviously he's
not his core is not a Liberty my decor
he would love to take more power if he
could but yet it seems like he's doing a
pretty decent job you know he has he
does have a sort of an authoritarian
mindset and and I'm I'm not even
convinced he's ever read the Bill of
Rights so I guess I guess that's an
excuse but full disclosure and you
mentioned this I I did I did work for a
Rand Paul super back when he was running
for president and then I ran a Gary
Johnson super PAC after that so as a
candidate I was a never Trump ER because
I had a candidate and at what his name
wasn't Trump as president it's a totally
different thing and I'll go back to when
Barack Obama was president I spent a lot
of my time organizing
that the Tea Party and opposing the
stimulus and the bailouts and Obamacare
and all that stuff but when he wanted
you criminal justice reform I went to
the Justice Department and worked with
Eric Holder and hopes to get something
done my attitude or Trump is kind of the
same way when he's good I'm I want to
work with him I've done lots of shows
supporting him on things like criminal
justice reform staying out of of so many
permanent wars and and stuff like that
that he's done but on other things that
that libertarians care a bunch about you
know we just had a vote on on
surveillance power and whether or not
the deep state would get more power
Trump's been horrible on that and I
don't know if it's bad advisers or what
if you care about debt and spending
Trump's been horrible on that so it's a
mixed bag but but our job when we have a
president is to make them better and so
I don't spend all my time railing about
Trump I'm hoping that he will he will do
some of the things that that would make
more sense and I was hopeful before
instance that that he would be a strong
voice on reopening the economy but he's
been a little hard to understand on this
he peaked he spent a lot of time picking
on the governor of Georgia Kemp who was
one of the first to unlock down their
economy so even on that it's it's a
mixed bag with Trump
but you know I'm I'm a libertarian I
don't really get on board with with big
government whether it's Republican or
Democrat you mean you don't think Trump
can solve all of your personal problems
is that what you're telling me I can't
want to live in a world where I don't
have to worry who the president is
that's how naive I am like if if you had
a president they actually would you mad
yeah
um all right so let's let's move off
Trump you mentioned Rand Paul and since
you did work with him for a little bit I
had him on last week and one of the
things that I said to him was sort of
exactly what you just laid out there
about Trump which is that one of the
reasons I'm more okay now with Trump is
that Rand Paul has become one of his
biggest allies and it's interesting
because Paul's explanation of why he's
ok with Trump is sort of what you just
said that yeah there's good there's bad
but I can try to push him the best I can
on the good stuff and the rest of it so
in a weird way it almost seems to me
that that's the best libertarians can do
we're not particularly good at getting
candidates out there the you know the
party's just an absolute disaster you
want to explain a little bit about why
the party seems to be such a disaster
even though so many of the ideas if you
could get people to listen to them they
are right and again maybe sort of
getting us back to the beginning maybe
they are about to have a real moment
yeah so like personally just point out
that both Rand Paul and Mike Lee are in
highly leveraged position in the Senate
and they they on any given vote they
could be the difference between passing
and not passing and I think they both
both done a very good job you know
neither one of them obviously Rand Paul
ran against Trump and Mike Lee supported
Ted Cruz in the primaries but but
they've sort of stepped up and said mr.
president I'm gonna work with you on the
things that we share in common and I'm
gonna try to convince you on some other
things and I think that's a really smart
thing to do and libertarians that
criticize that I don't really understand
because the the point is is to get the
right policy the points not to sort of
virtually signal debt that trumps an
awful guy and but for the for the
libertarian party and third parties
generally I think that there is
inevitably a moment where the two-party
duopoly does break up and and the the
reason I think that the Libertarian
Party has struggled so much is that it
is the two parties that set the rules by
which political parties operates and and
in Gary Johnson was a great example of
that they kept changing the rules of how
you got on to the presidential stage by
any historical measure Gary Johnson
would have been on that
stage but they keep changing the rules
and that makes it very difficult or
parties to compete because if you're
raising money for politics they value
pitch that you make to donors is we can
win this race or for a third party and
not just libertarians but but greens or
constitutionalists or whatever the two
parties that control all the power make
it virtually impossible for them to
compete and it's usually some accident
like say Abraham Lincoln that that
creates a new third party it's gonna
happen but it's it's kind of a chicken
and egg thing the libertarian party
would would have ballot access in all 50
states
would have a better donor base would
have would attract more talent if they
were allowed to compete and I don't know
how that breaks through they got to
break through somehow yeah so you're
saying it's not the naked guy running on
stage that's gonna break through is that
what you're saying so when I was oh when
I was raising money for Gary Johnson I
had brought on some Republican donors
major guys that were finally paying
attention to the Libertarian Party and
they tuned in to that convention on
c-span and the first thing they saw was
a fat hairy naked guy and they're like
yeah okay thanks there's other personas
to spend my money
of course that was before imposed lock
downs where none of us are really
wearing fence anymore exactly there you
go so alright so to just sort of bring
this full circle then so with all of
these ideas and with us still in these
rolling lockouts und see me in
California we're watching Texas and
Florida are you worried that that the
biggest disaster looming actually sort
of directly coronavirus related is that
if there suddenly a bump let's say in
two weeks in texas or Florida which in a
weird way it almost feels inevitably
will have to happen because that's
that's sort of the risk that they're
playing with that the media will use
that as such a freaking hammer to prove
that they should have never opened up
that it basically puts DC New York and
California in perpetual lockdown and
then it actually scares I'm doing the
reverse of the silver lining thing now
it actually scares the people who have
been fighting for their freedom enough
to shut up and then next thing you know
Texas and Florida are back in a lot down
yeah I think it's a real risk you know
historically and I'm I'm not an
epidemiologist but I've read so much we
all have just trying to figure out what
the hell's going on and in the during
the Hong Kong flu there was very much a
peak in the winter of 68 and a second
peak in the winter of 69 in the summer
things settled down a little bit in in
that particular one the peak wasn't in
the same places so San Francisco was a
hotbed in the first peak of the Hong
Kong flu so so how this plays out I
don't know but but I look at the same
data that that people on the other side
are looking at I look at what's going on
in Sweden I look at what's going on in
New York and other places and the way
that people manipulate data to tell
their story is is deeply frustrating to
me so yes we we might have a beautiful
revolution that discovers humility and
and localism and and in American freedom
again or this could be the cudgel that
that big government types used to
permanently Hempel
social tracing to permanently implement
a massive welfare state were where most
Americans don't work anymore to
permanently implement government-run
health care all of these things that
they've wanted to do they're trying to
do it now if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell